he needs no introduction roseann bars
with us stores an thanks for coming good
to see you thanks I have me Sean all
right
you sent this tweet up yeah actually I
was hacked
now I'm kidding good you haven't lost
your sense of humor you started out as a
comedian I want to talk about your
background and everything but I want to
get right to it
Muslim Brotherhood Planet of the Apes
you're talking about Valerie Jarrett
yeah and obviously you keep what were
you thinking when you said that I know
you said people shouldn't defend you
oh I just didn't want to get into the
whole game of it that is a political
tweet and you know I've been on Twitter
for a long time and I'm always let's put
it this way I walked away in 2012 when I
ran for president of the Socialist Party
and I I saw for myself that it wasn't
where my values were at after all and I
began to read more and expand the little
tiny bit of sanction news that I used to
read instead I started reading alternate
opinions I learned more and so I
corrected myself and now I live and I
told they BC this at the beginning I'll
I will always defend Israel because I'm
a Jew and I also have family that lives
there in Israel yeah so I that is a
tweet about asking for accountability
from the previous administration about
the Iran deal which Valerie Jarrett is
the author of and that was what was in
my head okay let's go back to you do
understand now I do did you not
understand when you tweeted it out no I
was so shocked was good what do you
understand well I don't understand a lot
to tell you the truth the first thing
was shocked that they were saying it was
when it's political and I that was a
hard one to take and then everybody
started saying I was a racist which is
like the worst thing that you can call a
Jewish person especially one who like me
grew up with Holocaust survivors and at
age three because of that fact I took
about two my god that I would always
fight extremism on either side right or
left and for a long time I thought I was
fighting it on the right by being really
left and then I just slowly woke up and
saw that both extremes are not where my
values are my values are in the middle
and I believe that we have the right to
ask for accountability for where our tax
money goes and when I ran for president
in 2012 I I ran as the representative
the Black Caucus of the Green Party and
they trusted me so much - black people
chose me and I was humbled by that and I
ran on an anti-racist you know Clinton's
drug wars and what that means that one
in every four african-american males are
in prison for pot and lesser I mean it's
just I'm very informed I'm not you know
always been political my comedy is
political do you see now yeah what in
other words I guess I'm trying to
ascertain Roseanne is that the reaction
was universal well it seemed that way
and well in many ways it was what do you
see about it now I mean in other words I
know you tweeted out apologies yeah an
opportunity to really talk to people
well I've apologized a lot it's been two
months and I I feel that I have
apologized and explained and
asked for forgiveness and made
recompense those are the that's part of
my religion you said that a rabbi shmuel
yeah because there's four parts of being
forgiven in order to come back into your
own good graces and I was so sad that
people thought it was racist and then I
went into the whole thing about the
whole discussion of racism and that blew
my mind because it's so much a part of
what the show I was doing was about and
I'm like why can they not see my work
and and then I got really messed up
thinking in this world it seems as if
words matter more than actions but in
the real life world actions matter more
than words and my actions over thirty
years as an artist and a comedian I've
always been against the abuse of power
towards all marginalized groups but now
I feel like both the left and the right
have marginalized the middle and it's
just too crazy and the thing that broke
my heart the most I have to say this is
that I have african-american children in
my family and in my loved media family
yeah and in my love being circle and
Asians - and Hispanic people and Jews
get around let's put it like that but I
felt so bad for those kids because I
loved them and I didn't want them to
think of me like that you know and and I
know and I was so sad and I'm so sad
that anyone thinks that of me but I'm
not that person
and I was going through a lot of very
hard time you know how would you like it
to be sitting in a room with 25 people
who think Trump is the worst thing
that's ever happened to the United
States how would you like it could you
do your job
it happens to me every day yeah a lot of
people that don't like what I have to
say in
Circle oh I don't know if you read a lot
about Sean Hannity but it isn't this is
here's what I really that work on your
show or like that there's plenty of
people around here that disagree with
every word I say and hate what I stand
for absolutely disagree Adam it was made
adamantly with me but you know I signed
up I give strong opinions and some
people disagree but I have no problem
with people disagree here's what I don't
either but that's what that's what upset
me so badly because I like to hear all
sides that's how I form a store well you
I have a whole list of stuff you said
about Republicans and Catholics with
which you know about added about
everybody listen I I hate everyone
equally
but obviously you're kidding no but
everybody deserves to be joked about
what I want anybody who's in any kind of
position of power deserves to have a
joke about them and if they can't laugh
at themselves then that means something
if you can't laugh at yourself first
before I start laughing everybody else
Batman's not how you started your career
by yeah didn't domestic goddess yeah and
you punk a lot of fun at yourself I tell
more jokes about myself than I do
anybody else because to me comedy is
very personal that's what makes it funny
that's what made people like the
Roseanne show because they saw
themselves in or had an aunt or in the
mom or their sister somebody in their
family was you know a loud outspoken
woman who loved her family and that was
what I was so excited about to come back
to television was to show that that
family is also also multiracial and
lives next door to Muslims whose ideas
they don't agree with that was what I
brought to television and what kicked
everybody's ass in the ratings and they
should be so lucky that they'll ever get
anywhere near that and they can't take
that away from me no matter what's
happened guess this is an opportunity or
a lot of people Roseanne that are not on
social media yeah maybe have it read
your apology's yeah there's not and put
well there probably are you off now
Twitter forever well my kids too
away from me forever bother you could
always get another phone but here's the
I think of very high death for those
people though that and I'll put up some
of the apologies here that you have
tweeted out but there are still a lot of
people that look at that comment and
they think that you they cannot believe
that you didn't know better yeah I know
but I did I want you to address that
address those people um you know I made
a mistake
obviously it cost me everything my
life's work everything I made a mistake
and I paid the price for it but no I did
not know she was like a lot of Americans
including a lot of people of all types
they didn't know either you know I read
that you said that you didn't and you
had this crazy video this week what was
what what I was so mad while I was
filming this thing too you know my real
apology which followed it but I just
everybody was like well you're not
addressing this correctly and so I just
lost it and everybody started laughing
so I go out put it up there all right
Joe calorie Valerie Jarrett yeah
watching now no she said she wouldn't
watch she said she wouldn't yeah but
you'll hear about it yeah my question is
I want you to address her because she
was and and maybe not just her but maybe
people in the community that are so
outrageous outraged uh-huh about it
I want you to address them power over
your heart and tell them here's what I
have to say let's talk about it let's
really turn this into a teachable moment
we need to talk about race and all
everything that's connected to it
including not knowing that someone who's
looks like me her skin tone is like mine
and I'm brown I didn't know she was
african-american
I assumed because she was you know from
Iran and lived in Iran for such a long
time and
writes about how she she and Barack
Obama hung out for a long time and the
reason they were so tight and such
friends is because they they don't like
the idea of American exceptionalism they
like that you know every country has its
own culture and we should respect them
and this and that
mmm okay that's kind of a globalist way
of thinking but I'm like I can talk to
people like that
but I don't think a state that kills
gays and you know stones great victims
yeah and it's a brutal where people
aren't about drinking water and they
have no rights women have no rights
I don't think that is like America
America is not like that America is a
place where I a loudmouth old gorgeous
Jewish woman comedian I'm allowed
freedom of speech is this the freedom of
speech you wanted to use it's because I
well of course I look back and go come
on Sean get real I mean it cost me
everything
no I wish I had worded it better but I'm
going to let them tell me what I meant
and that's what makes me so mad because
I know myself and I will speak for
myself and I won't have you know any
people who don't share my culture tell
me what I meant
and you know they call me racist on the
left for a long time ever since I said
the Jewish people have a right to live
in their ancestral homeland that's
racism to them to the to the far left of
which I used to be one of but I don't
want to be one of you I want to be one
of many because I like the whole thing
about America that this is where we have
a melting pot and we speak to each other
and we unite and we get common things
such as we're in the hell that our tax
money go I mean where did it go and how
can a president just ship pallets of
cash to another country without that
going through Congress you didn't say
this in the beginning
you didn't say this was about Iran I did
too I'm on there every damn day talking
about a particular comment about are you
gonna take one comment out of a
conversation I'd arguing with you I'm
trying to get out I'm just sayin but
that is what they did
and this was a continuing conversation
about the rights of people in Iran to
throw off their overlords I guess what
I'm listening to you is I guys I said
have you talked at Valerie Jarrett
directly I would say this Valerie
let's discuss this don't assume that you
know what I meant because I think you
don't know what I meant and I would like
to make it clear to you what I did meant
mean and I would like to find a way past
all that to really discuss the issue at
hand and to try to find common ground
between us would you want to say sorry
to her directly would you like to talk
well I have already have you talked to
you haven't told no I haven't called her
cuz I was like thinking what would be
like everything to say to call her yeah
you think she I'm afraid she starts
screaming throw the phone down hope you
picked up vibe if I had her number and I
handed the phone to you right now what
was the first thing you'd say to her
Walt do you want to do it no I'm asking
because maybe power favors got her no
numbers no nobody but if you did call
her this is and I think it's the
important thing you're saying you want
to talk about issues and this is a
bigger picture at a teachable moment I
would think the first thing you'd want
to do if it was me I would want to say I
am I want her to hear my voice say I am
so sorry and I know you've tweeted it
and I know you said it but now that you
have a very different perspective on the
comments I would assume you'd want to
start there well I already have said I'm
sorry for two months I know that way
you'd want to say it directly to her is
what I'm asking oh yeah if she was on
the phone or sent me me no yeah well
she's not but if she's watching I'm so
sorry that you thought I was racist and
that you thought that my tweet was
racist because it wasn't it was
political and I'm sorry for the
misunderstanding that caused my ill
worded
sweet and you know I I'm sorry that you
feel harmed and hurt not I never meant
that and and for that I apologize
I I never meant to hurt anybody or say
anything negative about an entire race
of people which I think thirty years of
my work can attest to let me go beyond
that and just talk about class I tell
her she's got to get a new haircut
I mean seriously she sneeze new haircut
people say that about me all the time so
I'm surprised I would imagine you'd say
that about me yeah there yeah it needs
to go over more towards a society seems
like it's in the middle too much let me
ask this it's also impacted and I know
that you tweeted out there's a whole
this was the biggest I actually have the
numbers I think after they watch with
DVR viewing twenty seven million people
I mean of course I want to apologize to
all of them to and say you know you've
heard my explanation the first part of
this show and I hope you'll try to
understand me and accept my apologies
for the part in this big
misunderstanding let me ask you you also
did it like 2:30 in the morning yeah you
are on ambien yeah were you drinking
yeah I told you that it was a Memorial
Day I had two beers
just two yeah okay they can't be a lot I
can't drink you take care of beers
mm-hmm and there's a there's a whole
other there was a whole lot of other
physical things going on in my life too
now do you want me to talk about that
well I've actually you actually have
read a lot of her yeah I just know what
you did okay I've read a lot about you
and it's actually I didn't know all of
this how you have said in the past you
said wants to Larry King that you suffer
from multiple personality disorder well
I don't suffer from
anymore you don't I enjoy it you enjoy
multiple person Wow okay and you said
that well you just do crazy things and
you don't really know you do or don't
want to do
Wow that happened in your life now Wow I
guess it does if you're drunk
you called it all do you get drunk a lot
you have mouth now I don't know
I'm also once you develop it though you
thought to develop you like drinking you
wish you could drink you just said you
can't drink I know I have no tolerance I
take three kinds of antidepressants
every day ya know two kinds now two
kinds once a blood-pressure pill so
that's three I take an antidepressant
and a blood-pressure pill and then I
take some more antidepressants and I
read in the Seattle Times when you're
out promoting your book this is in 1994
your father abused you sexually well
that on your mother psychologically that
you would cover yourself and catch up
lie on the floor play dead until little
Roseanne cried because of allegations
your parents would deny their that's
wrong I couldn't catch up on laid on the
floor for a joke for when my mom came in
and she'd think I was dead how old were
you when you're sexually abused well now
I have a whole different view of that
you don't think you were sexually abused
um I think I was emotionally abused and
you said your mother's psychological
your father's sexual yeah everybody my
whole family's messed up do you do you
think you you really serious question
because you've said in multiple
interviews that you had multiple
personalities yeah so I guess the
question then is do you think that any
of this plays into I have something
you've had crazy moments let's just be
honest we'll call it well your shouldn't
call a mental health patient crazy okay
you've had some very fun that's one
funny thing that Tom Arnold said never
call a crazy person crazy
oh man that's it but I have mental
health issues yeah how Howie how
have how bad have they have gotten for
you with that terrible how been told
people as bad as it gets
you ever institutionalized honey that's
like going to the beach for me it's
seriously I've been hospitalized a lot
yeah several times yes
you think in in a lot of ways I've I
love comedians I've watched everyone
from Richard Pryor
I've watched Chris Rock I watched every
stand-up comedian I want to thank you
and everybody and it seems that I might
be way off base a and I said if I am
telling me that the creative way off
face
thank you Wow the creative genius for
comedians
it's like the blessing is their curse
and being a creative genius no I'm
serious no but I know I am but anyway no
but I am your domestic goddess yeah
understood that part of your psyche or
brain is really close to the madness
they're very close